hey what's up this is why I love making
money so much I love making money it's
good for me it's almost like I'm
addicted to business and it's like a
drug and the reason I love making money
so much is because I realized that
making money is not about taking money
from people it's not like I have money
therefore you don't but otherwise I
don't hate making money because I'm
taking from people making money is
actually about giving so much value and
solving so many problems for people that
then they give you money or you just
make money as a result so I've just done
some crazy business deals just this
morning just this morning it's like
10:00 a.m.
no less it's 9:00 a.m. what happened in
a workout session in between rats I've
been I've been selling off some houses
selling off some estate solving some
problems being and and and people are
like crying with tears of joy thanking
me and as a result I'm making hundreds
of thousands of pounds because and and
and and that would have been fun that
concert would have been foreign to me
before but now it's level of course the
person that sold the most problems is
the person who makes the most money so
never think that being rich is about
being greedy being rich is about making
other people poor actually being rich
and making money is just about solving
bigger problems so that's one message
for today so get rich solve problems
help people and then with the money that
you make not only is it ethical and
honorable and Noble to make money but
then it gives you also the opportunity
to then be generous with that money so
that's a double whammy because you've
solved problems over here and you've
helped people and you've made money
great honorable then you're gonna give
money and you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna help people that are less
fortunate than you you have a duty of
care you have a responsibility that when
you're blessed to be a blessing so
that's a double whammy and then the
triple whammy
is then in doing those first two things
inspires other people to then do the
same so you share the journey like
that's why I do a YouTube channel make
money honorable give money honorable and
then inspire people so that has a
rippling effect across the world and
leave
world a better place than you found it
really really honorable so you know
although sometimes we hide away from
being wealthy and it's like almost a
dirty thing or which people agree day
all this all this kind of stuff
actually I'm unashamed to be wealthy I'm
proud to be wealthy I've worked very
very hard to become a better
problem-solver and I'm definitely not
gonna hide away because most rich people
hide because they don't they don't want
the hey I don't want no I'm not I'm
gonna keep sharing what I'm doing so
I've got some ridiculously good videos
coming up soon where you seen it out on
the road you'll see me doing development
you'll see me buying property selling
property solving people's problems and I
want you to be able to do the same thing
I want you to learn to be an excellent
property investor I want you to learn to
be very wealthy I want you to get rich
so that you can give so that you can
inspire and and well I cause you want to
go and do charity work in Africa when
I'm out to Zambia Uganda we're building
water wells and bring in water but also
I teach people about business because I
believe it's a true entrepreneurship in
this purest form is actually the key to
break any kind of poverty so you know
and honestly I know you get these
sometimes these do-gooders you know that
sort of say oh let's take all the money
from the rich and let's split it out
evenly listen that socialistic mindset
what it does it forces it forces where
it makes rich people resentful and
annoyed and it demoralizes them and
makes them not want to make money
because you just the government is
taking it off I mean giving it to poor
people and it makes poor people
dependent and like like that like a
puppy dog at a table desperate for the
money off of the rich people and it's
just really twisted I mean my thoughts
are that we should be teaching
entrepreneurship teaching it in schools
teaching people about how to make money
and then not robbing the rich to give to
the poor that's the really twisted I
think we should be what the key is
incentivizing the rich to be generous
and look after the people don't say the
people are too stupid to have the money
let's just force it off the people and
give it to the all-wise all-knowing
state to then distribute evenly that's
devastated everything it's touched that
socialistic communistic
look at look at look at East Germany
look at the countries that
whether that communism has got in power
and look how it's absolutely killed the
economy has killed the people because
ultimately what you're saying is let's
give all the money to the government and
let's just trust them never ends well
it's I think what would be better is you
can be encouraged entrepreneurship if we
taught people about money we taught
people how to be rich but then also
incentivize them we've most done with
tax breaks to then give to the poor to
then give to charity
now only a specified sum of tax breaks
but also champion champ yeah just turn I
mean this tournament saw the video keeps
getting cut because people keep phoning
me so champion entrepreneurship but also
encourage giving and just and just
celebrate it so anyway I'm gonna have to
cut this video off because people keep
phoning me into a ping yet but I love
you thank you for watching be successful
be rich give well inspire well and be
encouraged